[Musica]
nella vita abbiamo poche certezze io ne
ho segnato tre siamo nati
moriremo
e tanto di quello che succederà da
quando siamo nati a quando moriremo sarà
un'incognita
dovremo scoprirlo
sicuramente da quando siamo nati a
quando moriremo verremo giudicati
verremo profilati e verremo targetizzati
ora ho scritto un po di domande ma
pensateci quando è stata la prima volta
che siamo stati giudicati
quando siamo nati
ed è stato detto come vanto forse quanto
pesano
poi siamo cresciuti
e crescendo è stato detto ma è già
autonomo tuo figlio ma perché mi ha già
imparato a fare determinate cose
siamo cresciuti ancora
e tornando da scuola ci hanno chiesto
che tutti hai
paura rende ogni giorno siamo tornati a
casa molto felici perché abbiamo preso
un gran vuoto in una materia che non ci
stava tanto simpatica e invece di farci
i complimenti la prima cosa che ci hanno
chiesto quale è stata e gli altri è vero
vi vedo sorridere anche dietro le
mascherine poi siamo cresciuti ancora e
siamo stati giudicati per come ci
stavamo vestendo siamo cresciuti e ci
hanno chiesto ma sei sicuro di quel
partner
perché secondo me non è quello giusto
per te
poi siamo cresciuti ancora insomma
chiesto quanti esami ti mancano come se
ci fosse un tempo giusto per dare gli
esami
perché la grande sei grande e devi
iniziare a lavorare quindi non ti puoi
permettere di non aver ancora dato i
giusti esami
e poi quanto guadagni
perché è importante quanto guadagni mica
ti chiedono ma quello che guadagni ti
permette di realizzare ciò che desideri
nella vita
è davvero in linea con ciò che desideri
per vivere un'esistenza
piena
e ancora niente figli
no perché sei grande e l'orologio
biologico lo sai che poi se vecchio poi
vai a scuola e sembri il nonno
l'avete sentita no anche questa
e poiché macchina ai che casa ai 0 bla
bla bla bla fino alla morte in realtà
non è vero che fino alla morte perché ti
giudicano oppure da morto
e allora come adattarsi al contesto
preservando la propria unicità
io sono nato fortunato la vedete la
linguaccia
solo 8 fortunato perché la maggior parte
delle cose che vi ho detto pensavano che
non le potessi fare quindi non mi
chiedevano a che punto fosse
non mi chiedevano se fosse autonomo pare
altronde un bambino con questo corpo
mica può essere autonomo
sì è vero mi chiedevano dei voti ma non
mi chiedevano come ti vesti presentato
mi dovranno accompagnare i miei genitori
a vestirmi non è che potessi fare tanto
lo stravagante
non mi chiedevano del partner perché
figurati qual è la ragazza che decide di
stare con un ragazzo con un uomo con la
tua disabilità follia si vergognerebbe
del giudizio delle persone
e così via possiamo continuare con il
lavoro qual è l'azienda che decide di
prendere te che hai bisogno
dell'abbattimento delle barriere
architettoniche
chi sei più lento magari a fare le cose
sicuramente non è una buona manualità su
questo avevamo ragione
c'è bisogno di spazi diversi
vedete
tutte queste domande e tutti questi
pregiudizi mi hanno portato tanto ad
ascoltarmi e a chiedermi ma come faccio
davvero a potermi adattare a una società
che di fatto non è pronta
ad accogliere ma soprattutto a
valorizzare un bambino e un ragazzo con
questo corpo
e ho creato un metodo
basato sulla mia esperienza
io credo che la cosa fondamentale per
riuscire ad adattarsi al contesto
preservando la propria unicità
si è intanto
imparare a chiedersi più spesso dove mi
trovo in questo momento della mia vita
cosa significa dove mi trovo in questo
momento della mia vita
intanto è quanto sono soddisfatto del
mio corpo
e quando parla di quanto sono
soddisfatto del mio corpo significa sia
a livello estetico ma anche a livello
energetico quanto è sano quanto sto bene
in questo corpo
questa è una domanda fondamentale perché
tante volte non ci rendiamo conto che il
nostro corpo e il corpo giusto per
portare avanti il nostro scopo la nostra
missione di vita
io ho scelto che questo corpo fosse il
corpo è giusto per realizzare il mio
scopo in questa esistenza
non l'ho fatto da bambino non l'ho fatto
da ragazzo e questo mi è costato a tanta
sofferenza perché pensavo che questo
colpo fosse una zavorra
ma alla fine la verità è che siamo noi a
scegliere che significato dare a ciò che
viviamo
e poi quando sei soddisfatto del lavoro
che fai
una domanda diversa da quanto guadagni e
quanto ti piace quello che fai riesce a
svegliarsi la mattina entusiasta di
poter andare a lavorare ti rendi conto
che attraverso il tuo lavoro tu puoi
manifestare la tua grandezza puoi
portare un qualcosa di grande e nella
società nel fondo nella vita di altre
persone
che ti rendi conto che se non sei
soddisfatto di quello che fai avrei
molta più difficoltà ad affrontare le
interferenze interne ed esterne
quanto sei soddisfatto delle relazioni
della vita di coppia se ciò che desideri
perché non è necessario avere una vita
di coppia se non è quello che vuoi
non è necessario far finta
di avere una gran vita relazionale
e non è necessario far finta di amare
una persona
perché in realtà abbiamo paura di stare
soli
e quanto sei soddisfatto del tempo che
dedichi a te al tempo che dedichi alla
gratitudine a ringraziare per ciò che
sei per ciò che hai
il secondo passaggio fondamentale e
scopri la tua unicità
voi sapete cosa vi rende davvero unici
su quasi 8 miliardi di persone
per me è il fatto di voler essere
spontaneo
informale quando ho iniziato a lavorare
come così mi dicevano massimiliano un
coach si deve fare vedere sempre vestito
in un certo modo sai con la giacca con
la cravatta smettila di mettere foto con
il cane buttato per terra
mi stava per venire una parolaccia
diciamo cavolate
cavolate perché io credo che ormai siamo
tutti un po stanchi di essere delle
bacheche e forse c'è bisogno di
ritornare ad essere umani
e io ho una persona in difficoltà o una
persona che vuole raggiungere un grande
obiettivo la posso aiutare mentre o la
giacca e la cravatta o mentre sono in
costume al mare
insieme a persona
crede che io abbia bisogno della
cravatta per aiutarlo per lavorare bene
nella sua azienda beh non sarà mai un
mio cliente perché io non posso essere
il suo coach
l'altra passione sono i videogiochi i
videogiochi che io ho sempre amato che
mi hanno permesso di
scontrarmi confrontarmi con persone di
tutto il mondo fino a diventare campione
del mondo e che mi hanno permesso di
capire che nonostante io partissi nella
nostra azione di svantaggio perché
giocavo con due gomiti un piede invece
che con dieci dita potessi raggiungere
risultati straordinari
anche questo li rende unico
il fatto di essere stato premiato perché
ho unito i puntini perché unito il mio
essere il mio corpo
i miei talenti le mie passioni a quello
che il mio scopo di vita fino a essere
premiato dal presidente della repubblica
mattarella
equa introduco il terzo passaggio scegli
la tua missione di vita
non sprecare la tua esistenza perché se
esisti oggi e perché hai un grande scopo
nessuno è qui per caso e il mondo se non
ci fossi tu non sarebbe lo stesso
non sarebbe uguale non possiamo
scegliere se essere o non essere un
esempio possiamo solo scegliere chi tipo
di esempio essere
perché esistiamo e perché ogni giorno le
persone ci guardano ogni giorno le
persone soprattutto quando siamo
distratti e quando non vogliamo
dimostrare qualcosa qualcosa ci guardano
ci osservano e prendono esempio
e io ho scelto
che il mio scopo che la mia missione di
vita fosse quella di far capire alle
persone che a prescindere da dove
partono nel momento in cui si prendono
la responsabilità
della propria felicità come del proprio
successo e decidono di mettere al sen
servizio degli altri i loro talenti
le loro passioni le loro esperienze
possono avere un grande impatto a
prescindere dal tuo corpo
a prescindere dalle difficoltà che ha
dovuto affrontare
tutti ne abbiamo affrontato tantissimi
tutti la mattina ci svegliamo e abbiamo
delle paure tutti soffriamo quello che
ti fa fare la differenza e quanto se in
grado di andare oltre quella sofferenza
qualcosa in grado di andare oltre quella
paura oltre quegli ostacoli
e io ho trovato la mia missione
nell'aiutare altre persone
ad acquisire quelle capacità quelle
competenze per realizzare i propri sogni
ho trovato la mia missione del formale
dei cocci che possono aiutare altre
persone a credere in se stesse perché
oggi nel mondo dell'apparenza siamo
tutti molto più fragili e c'è sempre più
bisogno di persone che sappiano mostrare
la loro fragilità perché il vero
coraggio non è farci vedere invincibili
il vero coraggio e saper dire io soffro
io sto male e non ho paura che tu mi
giudichi per questo ti faccio vedere chi
sono davvero perché non temo il tuo
giudizio
e lì che sei davvero libero
e lì che sei davvero umano che li che
puoi davvero valorizzare la tua unicità
e puoi portare avanti il tuo scopo la
tua missione di vita libero dai
condizionamenti
6 massimino ma
io non ho tutte le risorse
nessuno di noi nasce con tutte le
risorse e io per tanti anni
pensavo che ha maggior parte le cose non
le avrei potuto fare perché quando
sommato una carrozzina come questa non
sapevo esistesse
esattamente come non pensavo di poter
utilizzare il computer
esattamente come non pensavo che avrei
mai potuto guidare una macchina anzi vi
dicevano che l'unica macchina che avrei
mai potuto guidare era la macchinina di
quando ero piccolo
perché come fai con la tua disabilità a
poter guidare una macchina grande
ma non mi sono accontentato
perché il punto è
che sia chi mi fosse accontentato
sia che non lo avessi fatto il mio corpo
sempre quello era
io il mio corpo non lo posso cambiare
cv dico non lo voglio neanche cambiare
e tutti noi partiamo
con delle capacità date anche dalle
esperienze che abbiamo vissuto
ma tutti noi soprattutto viviamo ogni
giorno con tantissimo da imparare
e il problema è che troppo spesso ci
soffermiamo su ciò che ci manca invece
di chiederci cosa posso fare per
ottenere ciò di cui ho bisogno per
realizzare i miei sogni
ma per farci questa domanda dobbiamo
chiederci prima io un sogno l'ho
perché se tu oggi non hai un sogno
davvero grande davvero potente che ti
accende dentro avrei molti più motivi
per trovare delle scuse
avrei molti più motivi per trovare i
perché non puoi ottenere ciò che
desideri
ma se capisci
dove ti trovi rispetto a dove vuoi
andare se capisci quali sono i tuoi
talenti le tue passioni
in che modo dare valore alle tue
esperienze di vita e le mette al
servizio di altre persone
decidendo di non fermarti davanti agli
ostacoli ma di prenderti tutte le
risorse delle quali hai bisogno per
realizzarti
a quel punto
ti rendi conto
che c'è sempre un motivo per essere
felici a quel punto ti rendi conto che
la tua felicità dipende davvero da te
perché quando ti manca qualcosa e vai a
prendertela la tua autostima cresce
notevolmente perché quando la società ti
dice che devi essere in un modo e tu
decidi di essere coerente con ciò che
senti dentro e non ti fai frenare e non
ti fai condizionare la tua autostima
cresce notevolmente
perché senti che non hai più bisogno di
confrontarti con la vita di qualcun
altro che non guardi più cosa fa il tuo
vicino il tuo competitor
guardi soltanto quali passi ai percorso
da quando sei nato ad oggi e ti chiedi
una domanda fondamentale ti fa alla
domanda fondamentale
sono felice
è quello che voglio davvero
domande semplici che il punto è che
questa semplicità l'abbiamo persa tante
volte
troppo spesso la dimentichiamo questa
semplicità
perché ci guardiamo attorno
e non siamo più abituati a guardarci
dentro
ma è solo quando riesci a ricordarti
dell'importanza di guardarti dentro e
quando ti rendi conto che un giorno non
ti pentirai per ciò che non hai fatto
perché non ci sei riuscito ti pentirai
per averci provato
e io non voglio sprecare neanche un
giorno della mia esistenza
perché so che oggi
io sono davvero fortunato non perché non
ho difficoltà non perché il mondo sia
pienamente accessibile
non perché le persone quando mi guardano
pensano ma lui può fare tutto noi a
parte penso che sia poverino se non
hanno visto un mio video o non mi hanno
mai sentito parlare
io credo di essere fortunato perché
respiro
e il fatto di respirare
mi permette di poter pensare
mi permette di poter scegliere
e sono le nostre scelte
che seguono i nostri pensieri
alla prospettiva attraverso la quale
guardiamo la nostra vita che ci
permettono di vivere la vita e di
costruire la vita che vogliamo davvero
quindi io sono davvero fortunato
anche se gli altri guardando il mio
corpo
difficilmente lo credono sono fortunato
perché ho scelto di smettere di
chiedermi perché a me
di fronte alle difficoltà e ho iniziato
a chiedermi se avessi scelto io questa
vita per quale motivo l'avrei scelta se
avessi scelto io queste difficoltà cosa
avrei dovuto imparare
se impari a farti questa domanda capisci
che la tua felicità dipende solo ed
esclusivamente da te e riuscirai ad
adattarti perché vorrei vivere
pienamente ogni istante della tua
esistenza grazie
[Applauso]